i haven't even slept yet but uh it's
great to have you on you know when uh uh
the the
rob the booker's like kevin farley and
every oh my gosh and then adam's like oh
we have to
yes when there's we got to have him on
and adam why don't you tell him you're
you know you're you're heroes in life i
think it's important for you to set the
tone gladly yeah um
look i grew up in the early 90s watching
snl dude yeah you know i mean this is
going to segue into talking about your
family and your brother and everything
but on my mount rushmore of life is your
brother and adam sandler of life dude oh
really like i used to do stand-up comedy
i had to transition out of it because i
wanted to make money at some point
but yeah
making things but i just remember in
middle school running around just
getting there like everything like
it's you know it'd be like what i said
like you're your favorite baseball
player of all time juan gonzalez like
meeting you meaning the entire gonzales
family would be a big deal for you so
no yeah uh
there's still a lot of people you know
that uh
remember him and that's why i made the
documentary because i wanted to show
people
you know what he was like and that
there's a lot of been said about chris
and that kind of thing i kind of wanted
to
set the record straight a little bit on
on some of that stuff and it was uh yeah
it was those are it was a great
documentary i was i was happy with it
you know well let me ask you you guys
are less than a year separated what is
it yeah no chris was like a year yeah
it's called irish twins right irish yeah
so you know i think he's like a month a
year like a month
uh older than i am yeah which is crazy
so
your older brother one year apart is
chris farley legendary yeah yeah but
like you have a lot of what he had we're
like irish toys exactly kevin question
so so when i think very different i'm
like chris farley light you know i'm not
going to throw myself on a table no
exactly
so yesterday we're we're uh hanging out
at this event and we're talking to
pampliano right
bitcoin and i'm asking about his family
five brothers how they're doing and he's
telling the story massive guy in the
bitcoin yeah he's he yeah he is and he's
but all the five brothers they're all
doing something right from 26 the
youngest to 33 being him the oldest
they're all players they're all killers
yeah and i said so tell me about the
household growing up well how was dad
like how was mom like and see how dad
was a worker six days a week but mom ran
the show and i said but tell me about
the whole you know dynamics cause i got
four kids yeah what was the farley
household like growing up that's what i
want to know yeah all brothers too right
now no there's one once there's one
sister buyer yeah who's actually the
funniest
um you know it was a lot of like because
we had four boys in the basement you
know we had a house that had a basement
we didn't have it upstairs so it was
kind of like living in a dungeon area
like sorry i don't know but we go also
wisconsin was cold
and i think a lot of comedians come from
like canada and wisconsin because you're
trapped inside
and there's no other thing to do other
than like we didn't have a lot of things
growing up you know other than
i'm gonna try to make you laugh you know
or else i'm gonna try to make you laugh
i'm gonna do something and then we dare
always darings i dare you to do that i
dare you that and we'd make up games
like does this hurt you know
she's pretty simple you don't want to
lose at that game
pretty simple game you know the oldest
to youngest give us the rundown well
there's barb who's the oldest was the
older sister she had her own section of
the house yeah so we couldn't go over
there she had carpenter's albums that we
couldn't touch and that kind of thing
and then
uh then they had the rest of us just
kind of like piled in an area we'd
switch like once one of us would get in
a fight and then i'd have to room with
john and then you know one of us would
get another fight we'd have to room with
chris there's three boys one girl four
boys four boys yeah yeah gotcha and and
what what are the age gaps before boy
for someone there chris farley you think
know his bible to be honest yeah i know
i know chris and kevin that's who i know
first i'm hearing that barbara's the
most funny
number two we get to kevin's cousin
john's the older brother yeah john's the
john's the older brother right john
john's youngest he's the youngest then i
have a brother tom and then a brother
chris and then myself and then john and
how many years separate though there's
only a couple years yeah dude what did
it happen to you you guys went to middle
school high school all at the same time
pretty much yeah what was that like i
mean a football team you know parties
keg this basement what was all that like
it was you know i think that i look at
kids growing up now and i'm like i kind
of feel bad like
we were out a lot like i'd be like sir
i'm out of here you know and i'd go be
with my friends for hours and i don't
know i never went home or anything like
i never went in front of the television
you know we had to make up our own fun
in our own and when when the vcr hit
they were like oh wow i'm going to watch
this all day long
but no we were making our own fun like
we're out in the out and playing
basketball or making up our own games or
trying to usually chris was always the
funniest like we could make him do
anything you know what i mean we could
he would do anything like anything like
anything no it's like you know you you
make these dares where you go i dare you
do this i dare you that you know i'm not
gonna do that like he'd do that craziest
there he ever yeah what's the craziest
there no i don't know
you know running you know this simple
one was running around the block naked
yeah which is that's just how did that
everybody go to school it's pretty
simple i mean but but it takes it's it's
not a very you know nobody came up with
the idea like really thought about the
idea
but it was the most dangerous thing yeah
because you're ultimately going to get a
call from the neighbor going hey
chris is running around naked again but
think about it if you're an expert at
physical comedy which he was yeah i mean
that had to be the funniest side and you
couldn't get mad right you see chris
farley running down you know doing a
whole mile around you know and then he
had the he had to complete the thing
though you had to you can't back out of
the dare yeah nobody likes taking the
stairs when we made these dares you had
to complete the now were you the one you
couldn't back out were you the one
mostly daring him to do the thing or
like what was your i wasn't what was
your involvement i was a chicken i would
make the game up yeah i would help make
the game but i'd never do the thing he
was always doing those you're the
producer and he's yeah
i would get the credit
but by the way what's the story with dad
that was like an instigator he would
come in he would like hey
it seems like he was he was uh also
orchestrating a little bit of this a lot
of that he would be one of those things
where he he had five kids that he'd rile
up and then and then get him into a
frenzy and then walk out the room and be
like all right let my mom handle it
but he was uh an asphalt salesman so he
he sold asphalt for a living and you
know if you ever see an asphalt crew
that's like 120 degrees out on the road
then we would sell the oil for the
asphalt and so you know it was tough and
if we didn't do good at school you'd be
like i'll get you on the asphalt crew if
you like
i'm like no right there's the ultimate
pat you know kevin's stand-up routine is
awesome and a lot of it you talk about
you know your family you talk about
chris
he's got one joke where he talks about i
got to find out if this was a joke or if
this really happened the joke you had
where chris came back for christmas with
sex toys for everybody yeah yeah he
thought it'd be really funny you know
and and he's like yeah i got this is
gonna be funny i'm gonna give everybody
a sex toy and i go yeah it's not gonna
be funny you know you're gonna you're
gonna ruin christmas and he bought too
many of them yeah
you said he brought 100 sex toys back
and so after you opened up the first one
you're like okay i gotta you know i got
a sex toy and then and then you open up
like 20 of them
you said dad's not gonna like this and
he brought this for mom dad the brothers
the whole works everyone gets a sex toy
yeah and the joke ran out about after
the third present you know and then
we're all just kind of like now you've
got to go to the hospital so he just ran
around the block naked there's something
wrong with you so then he just ran
around and how old is he when this story
happened
he was uh old too old to know like in
college okay gotcha yeah i was too old
to be doing that yeah no i can only
imagine the reaction you need to come
home like if i did that with my dad what
my dad's reaction would be the funniest
thing about him is that he would do
those things where he thought he
legitimately thought it was going to be
funny and i'm like this is going to miss
the mark on such a level that is like
wow this is gonna be so embarrassing
it's gonna be great
and he was just but he'd still commit to
the joke and that was part of his comedy
where
even though you weren't really sure if
this was gonna be funny
but he would go so far into it that he
made it funny right even just because of
his commitment to it you know would you
have to applaud i mean yeah by the way
they didn't didn't in the documentary
that you produced didn't i don't know if
it was the ep or or the the producer who
was that said
he didn't just like comedians that were
funny he liked comedians that took a lot
of risks yeah and it seemed like your
brother was a risk taker with a lot of
these things because someone is yeah on
stage yeah own his life too but i mean
on stage he would always appreciate any
kind of comedy even like just to get up
there i mean he did stand up just to get
up there with a microphone or get up
there and do improv we were in the
improv in the second city and that kind
of thing chicago yeah we all did that
and so when improv you just you're
starting out with nothing just like a
you know and a suggestion from the
audience and then everybody goes from
there and so just to get up there takes
a lot of guts it just does you know
instead it's it just takes a lot so he
always empathizes yeah if he gave it a
chance you know if you get up there and
you and you didn't try he didn't like
that you got to get up there and really
try take risks and and if you took a
risk you'd be like i love it you took a
risk it didn't work but who cares it's
about
trying it taking a risk on stage or
wherever you're doing it sure and that's
what separates the great ones because
everybody's up there you're feeling
naked right and you got to keep going on
and that's how you learn to persevere
and and come up with some some of the
good stand by jokes about those we had a
football coach uh that had this saying
which was funny like whenever you know
you had a play that you messed up
and then you'd go to the coach you're
like well i thought i needed to pull
this way and my coach would always go
well don't think do
and he goes if you're gonna make a
mistake make an aggressive mistake chris
always used to say that you know would
that apply to stage where you're not not
sure what you're doing out there but
make that aggressive
and then you could kind of fake it
you're like i knew what i was doing did
you play football as well yeah so what
positions were you guys no we were all
on the line because we were too big
let's get all the big boys on the line
yeah yeah we were not skilled i could
just see some farley's pulling guards
over there all right sweep left
no
we were all on the line yeah we were all
on the line there was no skill position
what was that like in high school if
you're you know he's in 10th grade
you're a ninth grader whatever senior
junior
locker room football like boys being
boys what was that like it was a
competition to see who could be the
funniest to me we valued funny guys yeah
and if you were a funny guy
in in our school or any of our friends
or even our family you rose to the top
you know if you could make everyone
laugh because you know that was that was
to me
that was the goal to be the funny guy
the guy that was always making people
laugh
you know and he was always constantly
the winner of that he was he won that
every time you know and did you in your
grade like he was the funniest grade
were you i was in my grade yeah yeah i
was i learned from everyone just it
seemed natural you know being
growing up and trying to just make uh
make the other guys laugh and was
everybody trying to impress dad like
what was the impetus for everyone's
trying to be funny in the farley house
yes yeah it stems from my dad was very
funny really yeah and i think there was
always this you know you just want to
you know
uh
make the big guy laugh you know if you
could make the big guy laugh then you
were you were in good well then he's not
mad at you you know you're out because
you know it's not like we didn't get in
trouble because yeah do you think there
there is a
element of
you know because when you look at
comedians what are what are some of the
dnas of comedians some of them lived a
very hard life right like it just wasn't
a cool upbringing so they had to figure
out a way to how to use comedy right
yeah some of it is maybe you're
and you got a person that is such a high
expectation person that you want to
humor him or perform or something like
what do you what do you notice being the
dna of great communities
like robin williams would you say that i
don't know i'm curious to know what you
would say i think they don't they don't
have good you know family
it's not ozzie and harriet you know i
mean it's not that our family was you
know uh terrible i always have good
memories of it but yeah there was some
struggles my dad was a big guy he wasn't
real healthy and there was some sadness
there you know and so
there's always this combination of of
that going behind the scenes and so
you know there was uh
i don't know of any comedians that had
like really
perfect like where your parents were
um constantly
just
listening to everything you said i think
part of being in a big family too you
get kind of lost and you want to like
you know get more attention you know
so i mean there's all that dynamic going
on you know with our house you know and
so you know who knows it wasn't like
really i can't say it was like really
dark but
there was this yeah it doesn't i don't
think comedians that i know
have that kind of uh upbringing where
it's a little difficult a little
difficult and there's either a poverty
or or uh
some kind of thing going on you know you
know it's crazy i'm i'm watching uh a
lot of you and a lot of you know chris
this morning and i'm going through a lot
of the content last night today i'm
driving back i got an hour job after i
dropped this guy off and
i watched a clip this morning of adam
sandler singing the song dedicated to
your brother i don't know if you've seen
that or not sure and let me tell you i'm
driving yeah you know and i'm like
i can't even control my i have to pull
over i'm like dude this is the end of
the song it's really well there's
something emotional yeah i mean listen
look so i i see uh one of the lines i
took screenshots while i'm driving so it
says i saw him in the office crying with
headphones on listening to casey and the
sunshine band song yeah i said buddy how
the hell is the making you uh how the
hell is that making you so sad he said
then he laughed and said just thinking
about my dad yeah so you can tell the
the affinity this guy had for his dad
your brother i mean there's got to be
that love that adoration was it that
kind of a thing yeah i want to make him
proud yeah he loved my i love my dad my
dad was a great man and but he had some
troubles you know and uh he was you know
and so i think
chris always wanted to make him feel
better you know he wasn't very healthy
you know and so he always wanted to make
him laugh and that kind of thing when
somebody's chronically ill like that you
know it's tough to have that in your
family you know so he always wanted to
make him feel better because he wasn't
feeling good all the time you know so
you know i think that's part of it you
know and i think uh chris had a huge
heart you know he had a huge heart he
always felt uh for people it very
empathetic you know and that kind of
thing we used to go visit old people and
he wanted to always go visit old people
in in hopes you know and but it was kind
of funny too because like he'd stay too
long you know
this woman is
pretty sick
you know she doesn't have that doesn't
have that long to live no no i'm not
leaving and they and the nurse is
staying with barbara
like you know don't yell and don't you
know feeling chris would be like hi
i'm crash
at an old age
and the lady be like one lady is like ah
get out of here
and then this other this one lady
thought she's like are you david my son
and he goes no i'm chris
and she's like david and he goes no
no
my name's chris and i'm like this is
confusing let's get out of here say
you're david
so you know pat brings up um
the tribute that adam sandler is young
ultimately what we're talking about is
chris's legacy and i mean
whether it's sandler's tribute whether
it's even you know comedians these days
theo vaughn his set
just had a picture of farley on it that
yeah your brother that's it that was his
set that's right and even you producing
our co-executive
co-executive producing uh i am farley
speaking of his legacy i mean
is it that's my brother or do you want
to kind of carve your own path how do
you balance being the brother of
literally
one of the greatest comedians to ever
live yeah i don't know you know i i have
to live with it so i don't try to like
separate it i talk a little bit about it
in my act you know and but like i say
i'm kind of chris farley light i don't
really jump around or do anything like
that and all his comedy's a little
different than my comedy yeah but i try
not to run away from it i mean i really
can't i mean people that talk to me all
the time now when they know that i'm
chris's brother they want to talk about
it so i don't mind it of course it's not
something i run away from but i yeah i'm
trying to carve out my own thing you
know but i'm naturally not as bombastic
as him so it's not as loud and great
yeah but people want me to do things
like wow to that point speaking of your
bits not running away from it you have
got a great bit where you're like you
know i'm the brother of a famous guy
and you kind of you talk about roger
clinton yeah there's a guy with other
brothers and other famous people who are
like
jim hanks that's a guy that yeah
i think it was bobby sladen that said
that to me and i think one time i just
laughed it was it was funny he goes
you're kevin farley yeah and he goes
yeah i know jim hanks
i'm like tommy what was that supposed to
be
oh he knew jimmy died he wasn't jim
hanks no no
this guy goes yeah i mean this is the
kind of conversations i always run yeah
you know i knew jimmy you're kev farley
yeah yeah and he goes yeah i know jim
hanks i'm like oh god okay
what is that supposed to be
you know so i'm like well this is the
kind of life that i have i'm like thanks
chris you know but all right this is the
kind of thing these are the kind of
conversations i have with people you
know hey kevin let me ask you this i
love your stand-up it's so good it's
observational it's based on real life
and if you love chris farley you get
some of that but kevin's his own man in
a brilliant comic my question is you
know he had those spade i love spade
right and sandler and those guys were so
close to chris and when when you're
around you there are similarities in
personality do they try to hang out with
you do they talk to you keep the
relationship going and kind of feel like
they still have chris in their life a
little bit well sometimes i don't see
him as much as i did i thought obviously
life gets in the way but i used to hang
out when i was in l.a i used to hang out
with those guys a lot more than i did
now but i don't hang out with them as
much because you know just people get
families and that kind of thing and but
yeah i think probably there was some of
that sure i think there was probably
some of that but i think
they miss him so much in uh people loved
him you know and and that's the legacy
that he has is uh his friends really
loved him and everyone on snl always
spoke highly yeah man it was so powerful
when you hear those guys i mean their
lives were really really ruined for a
little bit i mean spade couldn't go to
the funeral am i correct yeah no that
was too much he called and said i can't
really do it and
you know i understand i mean it's it's
it's uh it was a that was a dark dark
those were dark days you know and uh my
dad passed away a couple years after
that so yeah we went through our tough
time definitely during those you know
during those time but that was for
everybody and the funeral itself was
really really
that was one of the most moving things
just to see people how much she touched
people's lives you know so i'm i'm proud
of him for that you know
for all of his faults that he had he had
a huge heart and he touched people uh
and and got to people and and so he
lives that's his legacy and so you know
i look back and you know i i'm proud of
him for that you know so that's that's
that's a great thing for sure yeah no
one ever forget chris farley that's for
damn sure i mean he just had that that
power i mean you could not watch him and
not be moved affected and really have
this lingering affection for him because
he was so lovable and so real and he was
so daring and willing to go out there
yeah he lived like he he lived like
right out there you know where uh and
you kind of worried about him at the
same time like as his brother i'm like
oh
he's like a tightrope did he talk to you
did he talk i was watching uh uh i
watched uh
uh
howard stern talk to chris rock and
artie at the same time
they were talking about your brother
yeah and they're having a conversation
and what i thought about i had a friend
who was like a brother i never had a
brother growing up but this guy was one
of them and i remember when i i lost
this guy i remember where i was driving
when i got the call and it was the most
painful thing and the the
the
crazy thing about when we went to his
funeral was we were all sitting
afterwards all the boys like 10 of us
were sitting at the table
and everybody's looking at our table
saying why aren't these guys laughing
and crying at the same time
we were in tears adam when i tell you
we're we're laughing so hard and crying
at the same time yeah okay right and
it's almost uncomfortable because the
family's like do you respond like i'm
telling you this is how we feel about
your son we loved your son but he
pissed us off because we don't have him
anymore we wish he was here we lost him
at 27. but yeah would he call you when
he was in pain because this friend of
mine he would always call me and i would
always call him and check on him and
he's just telling me says pat i'm
struggling with this i'm like what are
you struggling we'd have the
conversation together would he reach out
was he someone that would reach out
would you have to reach out to him no no
he would reach out but then he would
isolate too because he never wanted to
be a burden you know to people so the
isolation is is it's tough especially
with drugs and
it's tough and you don't you want to try
to like help as much as you can but it's
something that they have to go through
themselves you know
so
it's it's very heartbreaking to see
someone that's you know going through
that kind of thing
and you know you just don't know what to
do you don't know it puts everybody in
this kind of thing like i wish we could
just get him you know somehow help him
out you know and that kind of thing well
this has been part of your life right so
so you've been
you've had every conversation every
question every thought everything that's
gone through it's been 25 years 97 right
december 18th i want to say so it's been
24 24 and a half years coming on 25
years so you you you probably had every
question that people ask but i'm
listening to chris what he's saying and
chris rock he's telling howard the
solution is
stop hiring him or to fire him no he
says stop any chris's recommendations
the way you get these guys he says
number one he says a lot of the people
who are in the industry all they want to
do is they want to heal them for a
weekend to do the shooting and go back
and do your drugs and we'll give you
everything you want but then let's put
you through therapy again to clean you
out it says rather than permanently fix
a person stop hiring him stop giving him
money stop let him go broke so he
doesn't have the money to buy this stuff
right and that's the only way to clean
up so they're going back and forth and
then howard says but is it really
the producer's fault is it recess no i'm
not saying it's not the producer it was
a very interesting he called the
hollywood people yeah and enablers yeah
he called them enablers because he's
such an amazing talent that they want to
capitalize on that right and they but
they want him to be clean for the role
but then
not interfere
and then already artie lange who also
has some major yeah
yeah i'm not sure if you have any
relationship with already yeah i know
already yeah so it was a really
a very interesting conversation i
listened to that same thing it was
howard stern and obviously robin quivers
and chris rock and artie all talking
about your brother but it was beyond
just your brother right it was people
struggling and they were directing it
towards artie correct yeah and they were
directly they were trying to find a
solution of what to do with these
amazingly talented people right who are
struggling with addiction yeah so i mean
this is right in your wheels i would say
definitely you'd have to put them in
depending on how severe you know it can
be it can get to be very severe which it
got to be with chris and i think the
only solution when it gets that way lock
them in a room and and and they don't
get out for a while
like for a while once a while the final
year yeah possibly more
possibly more when it gets to be that
acute yeah and for sure you've seen the
movie walk the line you've seen the
movie wow you remember that one scene
have you seen walk the line the story of
john yeah with johnny cash okay you know
joaquin phoenix right there's this one
scene
where uh of
june carter who was played by
witherspoon she crushed about what a
movie that's a movie i watched with my
kids my boys to teach them a lesson but
the one scene where
he's in the bed
and the guy that was selling him this
stuff comes from the side and you see
the father-in-law come out with a
shotgun saying hey get the
hell out of here
and you're seeing the struggle of
joaquin going through the
withdrawal oh my god and i saw my body
go through it we took him to
tarzana rehabilitation center i don't
know if you're familiar with tarzana red
brilliant center it's
closer to woodland hills we took him
there was like 400 bucks a day and they
had to be there for 14 days and
afterwards he was good for two weeks
and his challenge was vicodin he
couldn't drop the viking he'd take 50
he'd take 50 yeah a day and then a day
in a day in a day yeah and they'll do
anything to get it i mean they'll break
it into somebody's house
i remember me and a friend were at the
place right across the street from
conrad's i don't know what it was called
shakies shakies or shakers whatever it's
called glendale alpha brand uh or
central so we go there and i'm sitting
with him we came after a bible study i
was trying to introduce him to a pastor
to kind of see what direction we can do
to heal this guy yeah and he says oh i
forgot my jacket i want to go get it
from my mustang
and i told armond i said arnold i'm
going to walk out i don't think he's
getting his jacket so i walk out right
behind him he doesn't see me
[Music]
i walk to the back
and
he opens the trunk he still doesn't see
me because i'm hiding behind an suv i
want to know what this guy's doing
he opens it up i come right next to him
he he opens the bottle he drops he's
about to go like this i hold his arm i
take the pills i take the whole thing i
put in my
pocket i've never in my life seen a man
plead for anything the way he was
pleading in that moment
yeah i've never seen him played for it
and i'm watching him
and i'm i'm seeing the pain this guy's
going through and i'm like dude
i'm telling you i'm not you're not gonna
get it from me he says pat my body hurts
i'm telling you you just give me five
i'm like i'm not giving it to you bro
yeah three o'clock in the morn comes out
he's crying for two hours yeah obviously
i didn't give it to him that night i
took it i walked that and i went and
found out who was selling it to him so i
went and had a conversation with the guy
that was selling it wasn't a
conversation but we we had a situation
with that guy and a dentist was selling
these vicodins to him because it was
like a way of yeah it was a dentist
because he was making
five ten bucks a pill whatever it was
and there was so much connection but
okay we can get rid of the dentist
there's gonna be another doctor that's
gonna prescribe illegally we can get rid
of the guy that was selling it to him
and do whatever we want to him and
eliminate him there's gonna be another
guy that's gonna eventually yeah as much
as the survivor has the pain of what
else could i have done
i think eventually goes back to the
individual the individual the individual
has to be willing to go through it and
as much support and change you put
yeah
man but it has to you have to get them
off there's there's steps you have to
get them off like you know
initially you know like which is you
know tough the withdrawals and all that
kind of stuff then there just has to be
and i'm going to say it you have to turn
to god you have to make
that part of it because i think the
human being can only go so far
in in with anything that goes with
anything when you're struggling with
anything
you we can only go so far and if we
don't reach out
we
just no it's not going to work we're
meant for that
i believe you know you know it's crazy
you say that you know it's crazy you say
that we're at bible study one night in
pasadena uh hazmats i don't know what
the past church was called i want to
hear your thoughts and he's sitting
there saying when we're talking he's
praying we're the pastor's praying over
him for 30 minutes and he's fully in
tears this is a tough guy this is the
first guy in wilson junior high school i
got into a fight who's the first guy
that'll punch me in the face like he's
not like a lightweight we would fight
him and i all the time and we were best
of buddies right
and he had a challenge of trying to
please his dad yeah so you know the
whole thing about pleasing he he's like
i don't think i'm ever gonna please him
and it was a list of people that he was
going through and no matter how much we
try to get him to go through that phase
always coming back and feeling guilty
like he can't please folks yeah yeah
well was was chris going through the god
side was he going to
church was he going through you know
we're catholic you know and i think that
he had
you know the
i think there's a thing where he would
go to church and he would he believed in
christ and he believed in that kind of
thing
so but there is there's an extra step
where he just
for each person i mean there's there's a
there's a thing you can kind of like
give it lip service and that kind of
thing like i go to church i don't know
what's going on but
to really get in to really to really
give yourself to that is a different
level there's a different level there
where you have to like really let a lot
stop of stuff go
and that means 90 percent of you know
show business and all that other stuff
you have to let a lot of stuff go you
know and and just live and just be sure
and understand that you know none of
this really matters you know there's a
there's one other dynamic there too you
know chris was in his
early 30s right mid-thirties when it
happened 33. you know guys at that age
oftentimes are married right or they
have a girlfriend you never think about
with chris farley so he probably was on
his own a lot at home traveling new york
to chicago and sometimes if you have a
strong female a wife you know a
girlfriend they can be there to monitor
it and maybe you know be there and maybe
keep them from you know some of these
bad habits and whatnot but he was living
alone right when in chicago yeah and
that's another thing i would i would say
to anybody that's uh having trouble with
drugs get get find a girl that can
that's good for you not not somebody
that's gonna be bad for you but that's
tricky with men anyway to find the right
woman that can really kind of be there
for you and marry her and be faithful to
her and and that'll get you through a
lot too yeah you know definitely do you
know what's crazy about what you just
said so you're you're the age 33 right
you know who died at the age of 30
christ yeah christ alexander the great
john belushi lipsy hustle
the list it's a very interesting that 33
definitely wasn't christmas
all these stories
what's been your experience with drugs
partying alcohol
you know listen we're irish cali i mean
i have my struggles too you know and so
i go
i do
uh
go to program and that kind of thing
i've i'm off of it all of it now you
know but
yeah but to me it's it's it's definitely
therapy and and and god you know and i'm
catholic and i go back to my faith and i
i try to uh
try to to um
make it a part of my life not just like
something that i talk about you know i
try to make it part of my life it
doesn't always uh you know i'm a still
flawed person but i
but i have to make that part of my life
otherwise uh it doesn't work for me
when you see i mean obviously we're
approaching this endemic phase of what's
been going on with kovid but
part of the um
fallout of everybody being trapped in
their house for the last couple years is
a lot of people are utilizing drugs and
alcohol more than ever and you know
we're seeing a lot of overdoses
yeah so
being that this is more
pervasive than ever because of the
pandemic does it get you angrier than
ever do you want to speak out more about
it is it closer to home when you hear
these stories what's your thoughts on
just everything i think in general i
think there's this uh walking away from
god i think the whole country and the
world is we're walking away and we're in
a dangerous spot you know i think that
you can't do that when when the society
goes away from god then
we're seeing it i mean we're seeing it
you know we go into materialism i mean i
think we're you know in my catholic
faith we're fallen individuals and from
the start
so we're gonna go we're gonna we're
prone to materialism wealth and greed
all that kind of stuff gluttony all kind
of stuff whatever the 7 deadly sin
whatever whichever one you have which
you all have you're going to gravitate
towards that that's just human nature so
that's what we're seeing i think i think
that's what we're seeing we're just
seeing a bunch you know when we we don't
need god well we're going to go
somewhere else
you you you also have pretty strong
opinions politically i mean i you'll
you'll say some stuff at times and i
don't like to get cancelled or anything
yeah no not getting canceled but you'll
say you'll say what's on your mind you
don't hold back you know i try it's a
very confusing time but i i i try to you
know i see it now and i'm
i look and i'm like i think yeah we all
have to speak up but we do talk a lot
about politics in this country that's
for sure and i think there is other
things than politics in my act i don't
go too far into it just because there's
so much politics everywhere you go so i
try to get a little more slice life
stuff you know you know what i do like
you know what i do like with uh
what's uh uh so so every once in like
during covid like all the
hospitalization new heroes were risen
right we were kind of looking at people
and saying look i don't know how you
view covet you've got to respect these
nurses that were working on double
shifts and the whole thing so all of a
sudden
nurses became heroes right you saw these
videos of nurses coming home and they
can't see their kid and that one where
the guy puts a glass window he's trying
to hug his kid and the kid is like hug
me and i don't know if you've seen that
clip it was very emotional like okay i
wonder how
it is to be a nurse today but i think
what the last few years have done
and maybe this it's been like this you
know forever but i think comedians have
become very important i think comedians
have become very important where a
bill maher who's a comedian
is making everybody on both sides of the
aisle say what the hell are you doing
right you're watching brogan right who's
a comedian is addressing every issue
that's on
um
out there from a standpoint of i don't
know i'm trying to learn myself but now
i know and here's what i found out and
maybe this and maybe that but look i'm a
comedian right and you see
john stewart played and ricky gervais
and ricky gervais and chappelle
especially chappelle with some of the
topics he touches oh my god the transfer
will smith didn't get that memo right
yeah so so you see some of this stuff
that's going on and then you see what
happened with will and uh you know with
the christmas rock what are your
thoughts when you saw that what was your
initial reaction right i mean i think
what's
what we saw was everybody retreated to
their homes and then we went online and
you can manipulate that online we saw
that with twitter but in a stand-up show
hey just a crowd of people in my in the
microphone who's going to stop that you
know words do have a lot of power words
the words coming out of my mouth have a
lot of power that's what the comedians
realize like i'm just speaking words
well
words have a lot of power so when you
have just a
basic thing of me talking to you and
you're not gonna you're not gonna censor
this you know you're not gonna censor
that so stand up becomes really powerful
because like well i can talk to this
crowd here you know and
i think when
when the comedian
you know we're just used to having that
kind of power and like you know we're
not used to being censored
every comedian does not like that it
just oh it's that just
grates on us you know because that's our
whole thing we need to say our words
right you know and so yeah that is your
toolbox words that are coming out of
your mouth words that are coming out of
your mouth exactly the ability to say
whatever words i want to say
so um yeah when when obviously
as a comedian to see somebody come up on
stage is terrifying to me i mean i've
had a bottle thrown at me out of the
blue but that was terrifying enough
but uh yeah it's there's there's like uh
for every comedian that's ever had that
that's a frightening thing especially
will smith he's gigantic
coming at you like uh i could see
chris's face he's like what's happening
he didn't move he just stood there like
almost no face forward like what is
happening right now no it's in surreal i
mean surreal situation you know i mean
everybody's talking what i did like is
the guy on snl said the other days like
it feels like we've been talking about
it for five years
right well did you hear what ricky yeah
so so here's what ricky gervais said i i
don't know if it was on the view a
couple years it was on the timeline was
and he said the following he said i
would have uh i'll just read the whole
thing to you so
he says i'll get i'll get out of the way
i have not uh i i've got now noah will
smith material i've trended i trended
when that uh trended when that happened
and i was not even here uh what has it
got to do with me people were going what
they have
anyways and then he finally says
uh well nothing as i would not have made
a joke about his wife's hair
i would have made a joke about her
boyfriend okay
what she said you know what ricky said
so yeah and by the way knowing ricky you
think ricky would have done that from
stage i actually believe he would have
done it sure i think sure look at his
golden globes
for sure yeah and by the way here's what
happened with a couple things will
smith's contract gets pulled from
academy award slap the daily caller
story netflix and sony have stepped away
from their projects with will submit a
week after we slap chris rocket the
academy awards upcoming projects the
smith that smith expected to complete
have now officially halted as a result
of the now
infamous slap the netflix film
fast and loose and sony's highlight
highly anticipated movie bad boys four
wow bad boys four
have both been put on hold i doubt any
big studio of streamer is going to take
a chance in signing will smith until
smith's brand recovers until the process
is underway media analyst jeff box said
you think these are the right ones
they're making i do for definitely i i
don't think there's a punishment big
enough for will smith right now you know
when i watch what he did
and it wasn't just spontaneous and
here's the couple other things when he
was screaming at him and f bombing him
did you see the rage in his face i mean
that was not some little throwaway line
here's the other thing will smith won
the academy award and then he had that
whole speech
about what he did right about how he's
going to be the defender of you know
people that are abused what if he hadn't
slapped chris rock was he going to use
the same speech that thing seemed very
very polished and it would have seemed a
strange
speech for someone that was playing
serena williams dad in a movie right so
i look caa had like some big time
meetings i guess over the past few days
what are they going to do one of the
founders uh brian lord wanted to get rid
of him one of the other founders who
represents him personally you know
fought to to keep him and they didn't
drop him like they did harvey weinstein
and anybody else that kind of gets in
trouble in hollywood so you know i just
the more i watch this the
if you would think of one hollywood star
that would be least likely to do that
isn't that funny it's will smith or he's
one of them he just doesn't have that
reputation or at least he used to have a
reputation as being that nice guy that
non-confrontational guy apparently don't
know him as well but he deserves to
suffer some sort of career fallout for
this i'm not down for everybody just
getting canceled but usually people are
getting canceled for things that you
know they didn't have any ill will
towards they didn't do it intentionally
they just had an opinion or a belief and
people you know just decide to cancel
them but to walk on stage and steal
everybody else's night which is what he
did and slap him and it's just
unbelievable i mean and then chris rock
he's just playing it's so cool isn't he
whoever gets that first interview with
chris rock
by the way he already did his first
stand up and he says if you think i'm
going to have any will smith material
prepared to have nothing for people he's
still thinking about it no he's going to
sell it for 6 200 million dollars to
netflix i got to tell you i i uh
respectfully disagree with our friend
tom zenner here
this is just another example like what
did he really do he slapped another
grown man in the face oh give me a break
i know that you slap a lot of men
what do you think
at the oscars i don't know on stage and
slap another man in front of millions of
people all right hear me out here guy
number one before by the way tom we miss
you yeah we missed it
good to be back before
this
you know
monstrosity of slapping someone did
anyone give two shits about the oscars
the oscars should be thanking will smith
number one and so should and so should
chris rock chris rockwood's career
number one i was a huge chris rock fan
in the 90s
but he hasn't really done anything okay
you're wrong you're wrong tom let me get
to the let we'll get to you you've
already been offended by will smith but
this goes to a bigger thing
and it goes to the point of cancel
culture
if we're gonna start canceling people
because we don't like what they did how
far does this go down they tried to
cancel
rogan okay
they've been trying to cancel chappelle
we're talking about canceling comedians
and canceling entertainers
they tried to cancel bill maher people
on the left start trying to cancel bill
maher even though he's been an advocate
the first thing that you said kevin was
hey we're going to talk positive i don't
want to get canceled where the [ __ ] are
we at as a society yeah that you have to
actually worry about getting cancelled
for having opinions that's sort of the
beauty of pbd podcast where we're doing
valuetainment is unless you're saying
things that are completely extreme
complete misinformation complete hate
speech say what the hell you want to say
and let the market determine what's
right and what's wrong yeah but it's
usually the people that are trying to
cancel people are fringe people who get
all worked up in a frenzy and then try
to cancel people
shout out to a good one chris farley
right there's a good one but even you
bro you've been in hollywood i mean you
you experienced this why is cancer
culture so pervasive right here but
kevin before you jump in on that weren't
you starting by defending will smith i
mean that's completely different than
some trolls on twitter i'm not defending
will smith well my my whole thing is
cancel culture here if people don't want
to go see will smith's movie don't see
his [ __ ] movie but don't say that
will smith can't work anymore and what
are we talking about here no timeout he
assaulted someone on stage i i shouldn't
think anyone cares about that i think i
mean but you're equating chris twitter
twitter chris ross slapping a guy
two different things chris rock didn't
press charges it sounds like you want to
press charges because you almost got not
at all i don't think i have like a 100
million opinion here the point is i want
to get your thoughts on cancer culture
well now i think cancer culture is this
giant brush i mean we can be nuanced
about this
you know i mean uh
we you know i think it's like well yeah
will smith can never work again all
right can we is there is there a nuanced
approach to this can we
maybe he shouldn't go to he's already
canceled from the from the academy and
he's already uh you know done his own
he's already thrown himself on the sword
in that kind of thing but what is the
oscars going to do now i think the
oscars will probably
you know
give him some kind of a punishment i
don't think that there he's not going to
get off without uh a punishment from
them
but um i think once once once all the
punishment is dealt out to him they'll
probably
he'll probably work again you know i
would imagine i suppose we're talking
about one of the greatest performers of
all time maybe not working again
because he slaps someone yeah but
timeout no one's saying that he
shouldn't work again i'm saying there
should be some repercussions for walking
on stage and slapping a man at the
academy awards as a right he has his own
production company he'll do whatever he
wants as a stand-up that's so egregious
because
it's something that we all fear as we're
on stage somebody coming up either with
a gun or something like that well that's
what happens is you know when if you've
ever been on stage you're blinded by the
lights you the audience is kind of this
mob out in front of you so you have this
real visceral fear of like some somebody
coming out of the dark you know and
how dare you say that that kind of thing
so uh as a stand-up i hope that he i
don't because i don't want this
like oh will smith got away with it and
i'm gonna do it at farley's show i don't
want that to happen so i hope that
something's deterrent there like you
know you can't come out of the stadium
you can't come out of the stands you
can't do that you know so one time one
time uh they're doing the red carpet
walk whatever it is a guy comes and
talks i don't know if you've seen this
comes and talks to
will smith and tries to kiss will yeah
and we'll slap them in the face yeah
nobody reacted to it well listen a guy
tries to kiss you in the face you don't
like that you slap him everybody says
okay cole no problem we move on
you know
the the part like think about it from
this standpoint
chris is a performer you're a basketball
player if you're a basketball player and
somebody walks into the floor
and does anything to you you're not a
player meaning will is not the player in
that situation will is part of the
audience in that situation it doesn't
matter like let's just say president
obama goes to a game or trump goes to a
game or you go to a ufc fight yes you're
a powerful person but if you step in the
octagon and slap someone in the face
dude you can't do that that's basic
protocol the same way as conor cannot
step out and when khabib stepped out and
started chasing other people and
fighting guys you can't do that there's
certain protocols that there's
accountability the question isn't that
the question is okay he's gonna keep his
uh what do you call it he's gonna keep
his oscar fine he resigned he can't vote
anymore whatever the the the
um
you know what do you call it whatever
things that he loses right okay so
go and see other people who have been
canceled and then how long did we get
over it our conversation last night on
the drive to miami was what america is a
very we forgive very quickly except if
you deal with kids
and if you deal with certain things so
kevin spacey is kevin going to come back
anytime soon and shoot a movie you think
he's going to do something and people
are going to let that go you know it
hasn't happened yet okay it's been a
couple years i think it will do you
think america is okay if kevin did a
movie and then watch him like house of
cards next one comes out do you think
people are going to watch it i do i
think i think that's a great do you
think but you think people are over that
you know is it you know did he go to
jail for it are some people gonna say
well innocent until proven guilty no
one's uh you know he's been accused but
he's not gone to court yet so how long
will it take the real question is how
long before people forgive him to come
back and perform i think it depends on
how much talent you have a lot of times
too well's got a lot of time kevin maybe
one of the best actors without a doubt
you know how about ron our test right
isn't this kind of a similar situation
where they're throwing beer at him and
they go into the stands he at least was
punished for a little while he couldn't
play in the nba that's all i'm saying
about will smith we don't have to cancel
him but hopefully he can learn from this
and there are there's some sort of
punishment that comes from this by the
way why does chris farley decide or i
mean chris rock decide if press or
charges are going to be pressed isn't
that usually i know this happens a lot
but you would think the police see a
crime in their mind being committed they
just arrest somebody it seems strange
when you have to go to the victim and
say do you want to press charges
also yeah i agree i mean it should be
the cops probably do that i mean that's
what happens in the domestic batteries i
think that no matter if the wife
sometimes says no don't don't touch them
i think the cops still
arrest the guy
but i think that um also this has to do
with these
sexual crimes you know like if you look
at the three guys that are um
banned from the oscars harvey weinstein
and uh
roman polanski and then um who's the
third guy i don't know well there's a
guy needs to giffen but he's not yet
right but they're all sexual crimes yeah
i think so that's that's something to do
i don't think we forgive the sexual
stuff i don't think we do no i don't
think harvey's ever going to be forgiven
that's why i'm saying kevin is in the
middle of maybe never being forgiven
some people would say never but will
what he did you know how long six months
yeah twelve months
by the way speaking of sexual crimes you
see who's getting a lot of heat right
now is jim carrey
we've seen what happened with him on cbs
when he no he came out and he basically
was like if i was christopher 100 i
would file this ridiculous lawsuit and
and basically defending chris rock
defending comedy and someone goes oh you
know the beautiful thing about the
internet jim carrey
uh the [ __ ] doesn't go away so fast
forward or reverse to a clip of him when
i mean
after your brother passed away arguably
jim carrey took the mantle of the most
outlandish over-the-top comedian i mean
fair point
um
he wins the award i think it was
comedian of the year whatever it was mtv
award yeah and the presenter of the
award was none other than clueless star
alicia silverstone oh yeah um
silverstein silverstein
um
he wins the award and please
give it up for jim carrey comes on stage
grabs her two hands in the face boom
lays a huge kiss right on her face and
holds right yeah good five second kiss
she's shocked yeah the whole crowd is in
an upward keep in mind he is
the performer of performers of that time
this is probably 2 000 ish i don't know
if you want to pull this up but now
basically
you know people are like oh jim carrey
you have an opinion well let's research
roll the clip
boom i didn't know and now he's kind of
catching backlash so it's almost like
you can show them if you speak out and
have an opinion they're gonna oh yeah
they're gonna double back to something
you did 20 years ago sure and they're
going to try to cancel you now jim
carrey so it's a very thin line that you
have to balance right now yeah it is
what does that tell you though what does
that tell you i mean that tells you you
know before you're going gonna judge
just kick back a little bit and you know
uh uh
if you've walked on water go ahead and
judge all you want if you haven't you
know so i again i think america is very
forgiving i think america moves on from
certain things this being one of them
it's just a matter of how long i don't
know if it's going to be
a six month 12 month 24 months bill
maher said the following bill maher said
uh criticizing for telling jada pinkett
smith to put a wig on it right after the
oscar slap he says uh i mean alopecia
it's not leukemia okay
alopecia is when your hair falls out
there are worse things he returned to
the subject later in the show stating if
you are so lucky in life
as to have uh
that be your medical problem just say
thank god it's not life-threatening it's
part of for most people eighty percent
of men fifty percent of women it's part
of aging uh mark continued aging is
trust me i know it's the degeneration of
the flesh it happens to all of us and
you know just put on uh f and wig on
like everybody else at the oscars if it
bothers you so much the tv host has been
heavily criticized for his comments
which have uh branded hateful okay with
bill maher says do you he knew he's
gonna get he he when he wrote the lines
when he knew he was going to say those
those are going to attract heat but he
doesn't care i don't think
no he doesn't care i think this this
speaks to a lot of uh
you know when they they made it they
have an open marriage i guess you know
and so they made a joke earlier in this
in the in the show about uh
you know
um
them having an open marriage and that
kind of thing so
you know i don't know
it's it's one of those things where and
she went on you know i think they're
under a lot of stress that they seem to
be under
uh jada and will it seem to i hope maybe
he gets some help i think he is getting
some help isn't he or anything or i
don't know if he is or they said it's
healing season is what jada put out it's
healing which i don't know what you
think they should get a divorce i'm
convinced they should get a divorce i
i'm convinced don't be surprised if in
the next 6 12 24 months you get a tweet
or an instagram post from both of them
saying
we have decided to go our own separate
ways after being together for 25 years
we love each other
and but here's what we're doing this is
the love of my life but you know
uh you know we've whatever you'll see
something like a basil scripture
kevin let me ask you while we're on this
topic and tom lives in l.a so and pat's
from there so he's probably had a strong
opinion you moved out of la
five years ago
yeah but i mean
you're farley you're a farley you've got
inroads with hollywood you know all the
hollywood stars yeah you know we're
talking about the oscars the night of
the year for hollywood i guess what's
your take on the wokeness in hollywood i
don't want you to get canceled here
kevin
what's your take on just what's
happening and how left they've gone and
how you have to worry about what you're
saying and you mean you got the hell out
of there not for political reasons i
don't know but just your take on
hollywood these days i know that i
wasn't uh you know i'm not i'm not
crushing in hollywood i don't have
anything going on i'm not competing with
brad pitt for the role of troy anymore
all right i'll get my you know my hawaii
50s every once in a while or you know
i'll do an episodic you know once in a
while yeah curb you know those guys were
great you know um but no i'm not you
know so i decided let's do some stand-up
i focus on my stand-up and let's
you know i get the role whenever i can
get the role because yeah it got to be
weird with a lot of their politics in in
hollywood you know it just got to be a
little scary
you know with this cancel thing going on
if you if and and it's such a like if
you think even little differently you
know then you're you're not in the club
and it is a club i mean hollywood is
very much of a country club and who's
running the club is it the is it the
billionaires is it the studios is it the
producers the rich people the studios
the people with all the money you know
and it's falling apart though the money
in the control and it is a club
that you are either in or you're not i
mean it's like a country club i mean we
don't want this guy in i mean do we want
this guy in we don't want this guy in
and it's kind of behave it's like high
school it's it's very much gossipy
there's a lot of gossip you know i don't
know gossip is so corrosive
you know i don't like to even when i
feel like gossiping i don't like to
gossip about things and that's the whole
town is a gossip mill you know and so
that's a corrosive thing on your soul
so that's why people like oh god this
town is so gross
you know because everybody's just
talking about it everybody what's your
take on that zenner you live there yeah
hollywood pat you made a little comment
there but hollywood just feels different
la feels different it's not as glamorous
i think the glamour's gone i mean that's
the sad thing for me you drive down
sunset boulevard or you drive through
beverly hills it's still great believe
me it's not that bad i mean and now that
the pandemic is pretty much over
restaurants are full there is a buzz
there's an energy but if everybody
remembers it's kind of that first time
they go to california and how they feel
the ocean's still beautiful there's
still a lot of great places to go but
just that that spirit in the air just
doesn't feel um is great and to me the
glamour part of it it seems like
hollywood
is okay not being glamorous anymore and
i don't know why and i miss that and i
think the rest of the world the rest of
america looks for hollywood for that
it's a release
and they're so obsessed about bringing
up all these things that people already
have to deal with in their life and
they're getting bombarded with it every
single way they turn and hollywood
should be something else a diversion and
they've gotten away from that and it's
unfortunate plus the whole business is
changing streamers are taking over we
saw that during the oscars now that's
good because there's so many more places
to make content and if you've got
product and if you have something you
want to pitch you've got 15 to 100
places you can take it if you're an
actor you can stay busy so it's still
great the world needs the content that
hollywood produces but it's unfortunate
you know i've just told myself
until the whole until [ __ ] hits the fan
i'm totally still good with la and we're
lucky for where we live right so it's a
great place to bring up kids you know
near the water in a very safe community
so we're blessed and we're lucky with
that but and i and i love l.a i really
do and i'm involved in it and i'm out in
it every single day and i
part of me sad because i grew up in a
small town in minnesota i'm from the
midwest too kevin and i wanted to get to
california i wanted to get to l.a and
i'm sure you growing up in iran there
was this magical course about hollywood
i'm working on a new project right now
i'll be able to share some stuff later
in a couple months with someone a very
very high profile person who also grew
up in iran and came to america and made
a big name for himself but it was all
because of hollywood he wanted to get
there beverly hills california and
hollywood so i am an eternal optimist i
always
assume the best is gonna come and i'm
never gonna let it bring me down i'm
just a little bit sad that it wasn't
what it was 25 years you know what wins
you know what wins you know what i trust
let me tell you what i trust i trust
capitalism yeah let me explain to what i
mean by trust capitalism here's how i
trust capitalism um people call out dana
white well you know let me tell you ufc
this this this is that what does they
know why i say why don't you go compete
go do it start your own ufc you can do
it nobody holds you back yeah i mean i
don't like joe rogan's podcast he's
wrong bro go start your own podcast and
you share your thoughts i don't like the
fact that you talk about capitalism dude
why don't you go start your own show and
you talk about anti-capitalism and see
if there's an argument i don't like the
fact that this so watch what happened
elon musk buys 9.2 percent and everybody
was like oh it's just a passive passive
passive position right and i said it's
not passive a guy like that's never
going to do passive you know what news
just came out an hour ago elon musk
joins
twitter's board of directors
teases significant improvements did you
see what elon tweeted yesterday did you
see what elon tweeted yeah go to elon's
tweet yesterday yeah the poll go to
elon's tweet yesterday and look what
elon tweeted this this is why you trust
capitalism and those who work in
government don't like capitalists right
because capitalists know how to fight
okay so watch this
look click on that do you want an edit
button on twitter you know what an edit
button is you know how you got it on
instagram you got it on facebook you got
it everywhere yeah you see what you did
on the poll by the way what's that you
see how he spelled yes
that's funny yeah so so anyways he puts
do you uh uh do you want an edit button
what does this mean to you he's already
insinuating we're going to improve
twitter what does that edit button mean
to you use twitter a lot but who cares
the whole the whole premise behind it is
i'm here to improve and change things
with twitter that's all he's saying so
in hollywood go to hollywood
so you know people are like part of the
oh you cannot be on the inside and all
this stuff well this happened in high
school the guys that were the football
cool guys that you can't be on the
inside
fast forward 10 years later the guy that
you didn't allow to get into the inside
is now running a company called facebook
uh and who are you now you're you're
still a waiter at that one place well
zach won just so you know so capitalism
wins whoever is willing to improve
and take things and the moment you
that's the biggest thing about
capitalism that sucks so
uh i was watching
uh batman this weekend my kids are into
this whole batman thing i watched the
last batman couldn't stand it but the
kids started wanting to watch batman
begins and i said okay fine so we're on
the third batman which is it the dark
night rises you know that whole dark
night rises and there's a scene which is
incredible the scene is when he's in the
cave you know the cave when he's trying
to come out i don't know if you can you
pull up dark knight rises put the cave
and he's talking to this blind man
have you seen when he's talking to this
blind man this scene folks this scene is
a
dark night
rises it's going to give you the chills
here so
uh uh a
man i'm gonna read to you what he says
okay
so he's in there he's trying to climb
out of this cliff this uh what do you
call it this cave he can't get out okay
every time he tries to get out he can't
get out
he comes up he jumps up he falls down he
comes up he jumps up he falls down right
this whole thing
then one of the guys when he falls down
one of the man says why do you keep
trying you're not going to make it
he says what do you mean i'm not gonna
make it he says you're not gonna make it
he says but the child made it
he says yeah but you're not the child he
says why not he says because the child
didn't live a life of luxuries you did
the child didn't grow up with everything
you did
the child had nothing to lose you did
and he goes and he says but i'm going to
make it so he comes upstairs doing abs
and push-ups and all this stuff he goes
again there's a jump you got to make he
doesn't make it he falls down
then he drops and he sees this blind man
type in blind man that he's talking to
this blind man put blind man
yeah so then he sees this blind man that
click on that right there the one at the
top no no top left top left top left you
had it
top left right there go
yeah right there but not yeah put that
scene right there
so he's talking to this man and look
what the man says here's a script i'll
read it to you
he says to him
he says uh you do not fear death
you think this makes you strong but it
makes you weak
he says what do you mean
he says how can you move faster than
possible
fight longer than possible without the
most powerful impulse of the spirit the
fear of death you don't fear death
because you know when you're like i
don't fear that i don't fear anything
bruce wayne says i do fear death
i fear dying in here
while my city burns
and there's no one to save it then the
blind man says
then make the climb he says how
he says as the child did without the
rope
then fear will find you again
and he makes this climb
and he jumps he says i'm not using the
rope he jumps he makes it he goes all
the way out then throws the rope and all
the people that are in prison come out
what's the moral of the story the people
in hollywood
have had a rope
they've lived a life of luxuries yeah
and there's always going to be the
entrepreneur that has nothing to lose
the guy that's sitting there saying i
don't have the luxury of a rope i don't
have the luxury of a giffen or this
producer or that guy that's got my back
i'm going to figure this thing out and
then what do you produce you produce a
netflix then when you produce a netflix
who blockbuster didn't want to buy for
50 million dollars what does netflix do
net every big hollywood producer goes to
sleep fearing netflix hulu amazon all of
these guys the game in hollywood has
completely changed a guy like me can say
kevin why don't we make a movie how much
of a budget do we need he says two
million dollars we make a movie we go
out and put it out there independently
not needing these big guys and that
thing can do 200 million dollars that's
right elon musk can go buy a twitter and
say i'm sorry guys you guys are bullying
and silencing and censorship no problem
i'm going to buy your company that's why
you got to trust capitalism and that's
why i think hollywood's not in the same
place because they can't play those
power plays they once could play due to
capitalism that's true and that is
always going to be true i mean if you
look at like atlanta started the studios
of atlanta vancouver and all these
places you know if you open up the tax
base you can get a lot of studios and
make hollywood in atlanta
you know this is capitalism this is why
this country is the best country on the
planet because we allow that stuff and
yeah twitter obviously it's going to
change and overnight by a guy who's a
billionaire
and he wants to change it okay well he's
gonna change it
and uh that's what happens and that is
the beauty of being in this country and
and obviously the trajectory of all
companies they get fat and people get
fat and
and they start making mistakes you know
here's here's what it is one thing to
watch here's i make this prediction and
it's going to happen
guarantee
um
because you've never been wrong todd
guaranteed
watch the headlines the headlines on
elon musk going forward everything's
going to be negative they're going to be
ripping him in main street media they're
going to find flaws in him i saw one the
other day here is the headline elon musk
wants to kill baby seals or something
i saw it on insider i mean so now that
he's on the inside and he's going to be
on the board of directors with twitter
they're going to go after him personally
you're going to see a ton of negativity
what do you think do you think there's a
possibility you know he gets comfortable
in the board of directors here in the
next few months maybe buys more stock
because he's not done right he's going
to buy more
how does he handle trump is he going to
say it's okay for him to come back
that's going to come up at some point
and it's going to be uh who makes those
decisions does the board make that
decision pat who's going to end up
making that decision yeah i think so so
so that's that's the part where dorsey
is um getting a little bit more credit
now to say i'm not the one it's a board
that votes these types of things so
nobody knows where dorsey's vote was
some the people on the inside obviously
know and then he finally said yeah i
also voted for it that we got to get him
out right ilan can get in there and say
no yeah we may want to change it but
remember he's only got one seat
he's only got one seat he he doesn't
have the majority he's only got one seat
so he can get in there and try to
persuade and say things but they can
still say no
and gradually what elon can do is one by
one by one by another three percent yeah
by another two percent here by another
five percent here by another eight
percent here and then all of a sudden
boom this has happened many many times
we've seen one move of his five i mean
he's he's five steps down the road on
this thing how does it work with the
board how many members i don't know if
we can find out how many people it's
always an odd number there's always an
odd number so that you know protect the
voting so here you go how many board
members do they have one two three four
five six seven keep going eight
nine uh ten
eleven a company this side is going to
be 11 okay yeah nine or eleven they have
eleven of them okay
and how do you become a board member to
our company like this or you're invited
to generally no it depends on what
percentage you own okay and if you buy
in part of the arrangement could be that
you get under the board seat but when
you are
the largest shareholder now of twitter
tied with morgan stanley dean witter and
your name is elon musk
the guys that are in the board right now
want you to be also a board member
because they don't want you to do
anything reckless that's going to hurt
so now we want you in there as well it's
almost like a mutual thing where they
want both uh
uh to be in there but again i i highly
doubt what tom just said right there i
think this is one of his next five 10 15
moves you know here's the other thing
too is a lot of these people are going
to be
opposed to elon musk just in general
they're not going to like him maybe
politically or
on some level but elon just made
everybody on that list a lot of money
yesterday
did you see the volume of trading it was
six percent well that's how hot that's
how that was the jump in the stock there
was like 212 million you know shares
sold and the volume was 212 million as
opposed to like 1.5 million on friday so
if the stock goes up 25 he made
everybody on that board a lot richer so
how can you hate him that much so he
he's gonna have a lot more power once he
starts buying more more stock and what
he owns 9.2 percent right now and that's
just and it's just tuesday right
and they know they know one tweet is
gonna get them so last night we're
having dinner okay one of the guys owns
the uh
one of the four most expensive cards in
the world right remember the guy on the
honest wagoner tt06 sgc5 is what it's a
25 million dollar card right guy who
eats at all the best restaurants the guy
that he's at the best restaurants then
another guy owned a couple 52 tops
mickey mantle which is like a 5 million
dollar card they're selling the 10
million dollar spider-man issue number
one
uh i think it was great at eight and a
half which is pretty insane there's only
two nines in the world they're selling
that for 10 million bucks so when you
get into the card community and you own
a card that you also own and you also
own everybody here wants that card to be
valued more right so for example one
card is a mickey mantle psa 10. you know
it sold for 11 million dollars in 2017
right you know what they're saying it's
valued right now the cheapest one you
can buy right now they're saying
speculating obviously that's what
they're all saying 30 million dollars if
you want to go on that card today a
mickey mantle 52 tops right 30 million
dollars wow so if others do
own shares and tesla and you got a guy
like ilan that can quadruple the
valuation of the company i think the
morgan stanley's and these other guys in
the world may say you know what maybe
it's a little bit more than uh politics
yeah if you're gonna increase our uh
valuation here elon go at it we'll let
you kind of you know since i haven't
been here in four months i got to
maximize my time um i'm going to make
one more prediction and i feel very very
strong about this one i think elon musk
is going to segue himself out of
join the milwaukee bucks with giannis
as a free-throw coach no he's going to
he's going to work his way out of tesla
within the next year somehow some way i
think part of this is he's gonna have
more fun doing it he's gonna be more
influential i think he's gonna be very
very active with twitter and i just
don't think he's having fun with tesla
and i think he's to find a way to exit
if it's at all possible if a guy that
big and that prominent in a company can
find a way out i think he will be gone
from tesla in a year i think we need a
new show tom zenner doubles as miss cleo
and we just have all his predictions and
we see what comes right it goes wrong
you do love making predictions
whether they're right or wrong or wrong
or wrong they're not good
predictions to come to you so kevin you
you got an interesting dynamic yourself
you
uh in 2008 or 2009 i think you were at
the uh rnc convention or something like
that well
yeah but then you also golf with bill
clinton so it's like yeah
yeah
i don't know like i said i i that during
that time i uh i
was friends with david zucker i don't
know if you know who david zucker is he
uh did airplane and is he from wisconsin
yes i know so many people from wisconsin
that talk about david zucker and david
is a huge pack fan i'm a huge pack fan
and uh so david and i became friends and
and um
he wanted to do a movie about michael
moore which is like this is the movie i
did called american carol which
i played michael moore and uh it was a
spoof about how michael moore wanted to
take away fourth of july and so
i mean it was
i've always wanted to work with david
zucker because i love airplane and i
love uh of naked gun series and all
those kind of things
so i was just yeah i would say yes i say
yeah i'll work with you for sure but it
was a pretty much of a
you know it had a good cast it had uh
dennis hopper
kelsey grammer
um you know
david alexander david greer and um
uh leslie nielsen um john
john
maybe that's some of your political
inclinations john hang around with john
voigt long enough the next thing you
know yeah you end up at the rnc
convention that's why exactly i think he
wanted us all go to go there so
you know i'm not going to say no to john
boyd yeah so he's like yeah we're all
going to the rnc convention and i'm like
well i'm going to be kind of labeled as
a republican he goes you're going to
there aren't yeah oh okay okay so i went
and just just palled i'd never been to a
convention before and so it was trip to
sea it was it was kind of wild to see
that uh political environment i'd never
been to a convention i would have i
would
encourage anyone to go to a political
convention it's really kind of wild have
you ever spoken on the floor of congress
or anything like that no my brother
chris did yeah
yeah yeah yeah we got to show that i
don't know if we could show it was not
playing new game
he was playing new gingrich yeah he
played newt gingrich yeah it's on c-span
we can watch it mm-hmm yeah c-span is
fine
yeah i know i think so set up the story
if you would kevin so he gets invited he
did it on snl and i think he got invited
to do that i think for it might have
been something to do with his birthday
or i don't know newt's birthday or
something i don't know i'm not sure
maybe not by the way newt's sitting
right there right no he liked it
different era man
sense of humor back then right yeah
exactly we're a little more it would
never happen right now it wouldn't
people would walk out they were offended
they would yeah
i mean this couldn't happen right now no
it couldn't we're too political
yeah
we can watch it later it's an
eight-minute clip but we're too
political now back then you could you
know go have dinner with uh you know and
did chris care about politics it was not
a lot not even the least my dad was a
republican so i think that's you know
but that's all he put thought in got it
he didn't really think too much about it
i think he was more passionate about his
comedy than he was about politics or
anything well that's good i can see that
because anything that would because
chris was so much about pleasing the
audience that's the feeling at least i
get i may be wrong that he looked like
he was a guy that
was going to give his best and his
performance was going to be solid i
can't see him getting too political do
you think snl these days has gotten too
political i mean everything they're
doing with they did with trump and now
they get the guy who does trump he also
does buy it in but
clearly snl has sprinted left wow
they're making fun of janine pirro
marsha blackburn on the regular i think
lauren michael that show's been on the
air for i don't know how long i think
it's almost 50 years okay so just almost
just the fact that it's been on that
long is it literally a wonder of the
world correct so to survive in in the
political i mean into in on television
for that long you have to do and lauren
knows this instinctively lauren michaels
he knows we have to survive
so he's like what works you know it's
throwing stuff against the wall politics
works for us
so the ratings are going up it's
capitalism and the ratings are going up
and so he's going to stick with what's
going you know they've always got
chambers right if you've got a pitch
that's working if your curveball is
working you're going to keep i think i
think your brother played tip o'neill i
want to say at one point yeah he played
a lot of them he also played a guy named
howell heflin or something like a
senator heflin back in the day at a
giant chin and he was like he was on the
the clarence thomas uh
and it was it was a hysterical what are
your thoughts on lauren michael's in
general you have time to spend with him
at all i've talked to lauren yeah a lot
of different times he's the king i mean
he rules it over there so
uh you know he's i kind of like
intimidating he's an intimidating guy so
i i just say hello sir nice to see you
yeah i enjoyed the quote about what he
said about your brother though
uh he says because he's got this very
distinct like uh
not i don't know it's just very
straightforward voice he's like he's in
a category of people
[Music]
yeah he does that he's worked that are
infuriatingly talented
right that's how he described your
brother right basically saying that you
just have to recognize and um
and dive straight into it right i mean
it got to the point where they would put
it if you had a sketch on snl and it was
kind of you know reaching the point
where you're like i don't know what
we're going to do with this what this is
kind of a dud
he would find a way to make that sketch
good right so fall down or something
that's all it takes your brother you're
saying he had an instinct where he'd be
like i know how to make this funny you
know so
yeah so that's where lauren was like you
know we had a thousand sketches and
chris had come up with the solution to
like all of them you know he was a
genius that way but but uh
just find out what's gonna be funny do
you have some favorite sketches that
come to mind that chris did oh geez i
think uh
i always liked i put some in the uh in
the documentary that one whether he's a
talent scout or something like that that
to me it was just hilarious like no no
no he's just big on everything this is
hilarious
i think that was one of my favorite he
was like a talent uh agent and it was
really flamboyant the most famous one is
the chippendales one well yeah him and
patrick swayze yeah that was one of the
lunch lady
which which one is that the lunch lady
without a lunch lady with adam yeah that
was a big yeah
wasn't it the gap store him in spade
where they were folding up the clothes
lay off me i'm starving yeah no he had
like five of the top i think they made a
list of them he had like two or three in
the top 20 you know sketches he really
did well on that show how did pat
started it off with this but how did he
come up with the matt foley motivational
speaker
live in a van down by the river that was
a bit actually written by bob odenkirk
in fact bob just wrote a book about it
wow and he said that uh back in second
city when we were in chicago that's
where we all trained
and there was a stage thing that bob
wrote and he was writing it i think for
himself but he didn't want to do it so
he gave it to chris to play the
motivational speaker so wow they did
that first in chicago at second city
yeah and then they brought it up to
saturday night live yeah are you
following what's going on with disney
you're following like yeah going back
i'm gonna read this to you guys because
there's a new story that came out
uh on the direction these guys want to
take it so disney shareholders tell ceo
to stop wasting money on political uh
crusades okay a disney shareholder is
speaking out against the company's
involvement in florida politically
politics by actively opposing the
republican-led parental right and
education bill championed by republican
governor desantis ray keating an
economist and editor at disney business
journal said when companies dive into
politics it rarely turns out
uh uh well here's a suggestion for
disney stock
baba champig
uh get back to business that is
excellence and storytelling and stop
wasting shareholders money on political
crusades that have nothing to do with
disney's business we all have the right
to have our voices hurt on issues but
not on the shareholders dime keating
said interesting yeah very pretty
powerful statement what do you think
about what the keating said you know
you're used to uh strength coming from
disney for what
so long you know uh what 40 something
years yeah they had two ceos right
including one of the greatest that just
bob iger who just retired i think shape
is coming across as very weak in this
whole situation when you want to come
across as strong he's only been in there
for a little bit over a year you know it
always befuddles me because
why a company would want to be so
politically active i just don't get it i
keep saying to myself
there are other people who have
different political beliefs that like to
go to disneyland and like to go to
disney world and what happens when they
do start boycotting or not downloading
the app anymore right because it's all
about streaming for disney and and jpeg
comes from the parks business and i
think that's where you could see the
biggest drop uh when you come back and
you realize the prices that are involved
in going to disneyland or disney world
for the day and then to think that okay
am i really if i think differently than
how they project their beliefs are about
am i going to be welcomed there am i
going to have a good time so is it worth
it to invest a full day in it i just
think the numbers are going to come back
i think this this board member nailed it
i think he's speaking for a lot of
people and and it's not just disney i
think there's a lot of companies that
are going to be having these same
conversations because once this start
once the minor or the the probably the
quiet majority start speaking a little
bit more they're going to get attention
of these ceos and the board of directors
because how long can you take it you
just cannot continue to take it like
this so yeah when he came out i i was i
didn't do enough for you i just thought
that was weak talk from a ceo didn't you
i mean the memo that he sent out to his
employees it seemed like the only thing
he cared about was his employees
feelings and i maybe i'm old school but
when you work for a company i think
there should be part of you that is
appreciative for the job you do your
best and you don't have to let everybody
know all day long how you stand
politically so i judged him by what he
uh
released in that statement and i think
he's gonna have a challenge i really do
i also think disney's in a very tough
position because if there's one company
that is kind of in the middle of all the
drama that's happening in the united
states right now it's disney think about
it i mean how many of their employees
are lgbtq they just had a major walkout
right you're you're you're they're
supposed to be entertaining families
yeah espn right all that that's you know
that's in addition to you have amusement
parks so you're dealing with masks no
mass pat did a whole segment about the
difference between disneyland and la
versus disney world here in florida in
orlando right you're dealing with kids
so you're dealing with especially with
lgbt the don't say gay bill all of that
critical race theory being taught in
school um
just it's sort of like a bellwether of
what's going on in society and now you
have the daily wire what is that ben
shapiro's organization that's coming out
and they basically said they're going to
pump in i don't know how much millions
of dollars to creating
more conservative type content so
disney's in a very tough place like
whatever whatever direction they're
going to go they're going to piss
somebody off and if there's a company
that doesn't want to piss people off
it's the company that stands for family
values and
and entertainment and it there's just a
slippery slope into tom zenner's point
just get back to business i does have
you ever read any biography on walt
disney which i've read a few of them
what a man what a great guy you know i
mean i mean he had his faults obviously
but when he started that company was
pretty simple like he's you know it was
a simple
um thing you know we wanted it he wanted
to entertain families the most magical
place on earth yeah and it was pretty
simple i mean now they've been pretty
complicated yeah it's a giant now
obviously this is the trajectory of
maybe of what companies and corporations
do obviously you always want growth you
always want more money you know and that
kind of maybe that's the reason why
these companies twitter and everything
else you see and like capitalism some
drop-offs gonna happen and then there'll
be another version of it or something
like that but there's always this
trajectory of like and i see disney
going that way too it's like this is
what what would what would walt say i
always say what would he say you know he
was a savvy dude though there's a story
that came out i saw it a couple weeks
ago or maybe over the weekend but watch
this one what's going on in orlando so
when they beat b when they built disney
world walt disney lobbied the government
in florida to basically circumvent the
county orange county and be able to
build as much as they want when they
want to build a glass tower that's 25
stories tall they don't need county
approval right so i think they pay for
their own
management of the streets waste
management all this thing so it's almost
like their own ecosystem but republicans
in florida are starting to look at that
and say you have one hell of a tax break
here you have an incredible advantage
that we're going to examine right now
that has flown under the radar screen
for about 50 years
and there are going to be ways
politically for
a little payback here it's ironic that
the republicans of florida want to
regulate
disney i don't know well let me let me
let me say this part to you so so this
is where it makes me think uh oh and i'm
gonna push back with you guys and see
what angle you take with this i'm
actually curious to know how you process
this we we talked about nike when nike
decided to side with kaepernick after
the whole thing with kneeling i was
always oh my god nike stocks gonna drop
nike stocks gonna drop they're gonna
vote this is horrible i will never buy
another nike boom they made four billion
dollars like the next two to four weeks
whatever it was they embraced that and
they're saying like ah no this is what
we're doing you know so no we don't care
if you're gonna be offended or not we
think we're doing the right thing
disney's doing this year and i was like
oh my gosh i will never watch another
cartoon again with disney and all this
other stuff okay
we're about to find out if this
boycotting stuff is real or if this
boycotting stuff is fake
the one part that i think is different
the one part cause i hear this argument
from both sides that i think disney's
doing the right thing from the left is
the the one thing that uh i will say is
how different this is than others is the
following
is we saw what happened in uh georgia it
was a georgia virginia we saw what
happened
where the the main topic that parents
united on both sides of the aisle
politically where one side is like
listen i'm pro-choice
okay well i'm pro-life
okay uh
i i'm i'm about to you know entitlement
programs i'm not i'm about minimizing it
okay i'm about we're spending too much
money in military well we need more
military to feel safe
okay but don't mess with my kids
yeah me too don't mess with my kids oh
so
we have that in common yeah
well all right let's unite and then boom
elections show them what happened so
the difference i think
how
disney's gonna be going up against nike
because this is kids
and if they think for a second that's
going to be okay with parents trying to
i think i'll point out one other thing
too you know i think nike was defending
it one of their stars which is different
than
defending
you know an employee that works at a
desk or at a cubicle which is what
disney's doing the other thing is
disney's political beliefs come through
in their product right so it's not like
nike was only making left shoes right i
mean
you still love nike
right but with disney it's coming
through in their movies and in their
product and it's coming through on espn
the other thing is there's a hell of a
lot more competition for disney than
there is for nike and disney's trying to
become the number one streamer in the
world and they have a fight with netflix
and maybe with amazon and so i think
there's
less margin for error for disney i think
it can hurt them more down the road
because they have more competition and
it's constantly be throwing in people's
face is how they feel politically right
when you sit there and you you talk to
your everyday person they're going to
show you pictures of the kids what do
people care about what do they really
care about i mean the average person
going here's my kid doing this here's my
kid doing they care about their kids you
want to see the average joe get fired up
and want to
kill something mess with their kid right
so that's where i think you're right
where it's going to be like this is a
little different a little different when
you're talking about someone's because
you want to see a general populist get
angry
well what's the thing that we covered
last uh last podcast uh or last week
uh with jank i believe that they they're
gonna stop referring to kids as boys and
girls and now
these dreamers and wishers or something
like that yeah so when you know you know
what percentage of society doesn't want
to be identified as hey good morning
boys and girls ladies and gentlemen no
nobody has an issue with that but now
you're canceling the word boys and girls
that's where you get people with common
sense being like hold on
i was with you guys right yeah but yeah
what's going on here i'm out now i'm out
you know kevin said earlier that uh
the nation is lacking religion and it's
it's not you're just seeing instead of
god they're filling it with politics and
this is becoming a form of religion
hollywood
the politics the intersectional stuff
the
the vaccines the climate change it's all
becoming a form of religion if you don't
follow the orthodoxy whether or not it
makes sense whether or not it's truthful
whether or not it's backed by science if
you don't follow the orthodoxy you are a
heathen of sorts and you get cut out and
cast out you're going to worship
something you know i don't know because
human beings we worship things you know
and so you're going to worship something
it's not if it's not god it's going to
be politics it's going to be
uh woke politics it's going to be uh the
moon and the stars your own reason your
own reason it's going to be you're going
to worship something and so we're
finding that it's shifting
now we're getting away from god we're
going to other things
all kinds of different things
and they're not good
how about that southwest flight
you're so funny out of it you want to
tell that story go ahead adam this is
adam's favorite story yeah where can i
pull this thing up literally
are we gonna talk about this yeah well
we're gonna do it right now oh my god
you better bring it out right now
so apparently uh this southwest flight
passenger was very active during this
flight did you have this story in your
back pocket i didn't i didn't but i'll
pull it out
uh so apparently a southwest passenger
arrested for masturbating not once not
twice not thrice
but four times on a on a flight where
was the flight going to uh zenner it was
from seattle to phoenix seattle to
phoenix first of all who the hell is
tracking the four times yeah i want to
know that guy that that was stood behind
him and he said
one it's like a scoreboard yeah right
right next to the exits
let's see if we can read the story out
here
so uh
punch in on it so a man in a southwest
airlines flight is this a joke or is
this real this is a real story
unfortunately from seattle to phoenix is
facing seattle phoenix how long is that
flight two hours maybe it's probably
three hours seattle to phoenix facing
federal charges or pulling down his
pants and masturbating at least four
times in front of a female pastor oh
okay shortly after takeoff
uh antonio sherrod mcgarrity that's his
name he's an irishman right oh my god
was arrested by officers at the phoenix
police department when southwest flight
3814 landed at sky harbor international
however mcgarrity told cops that he
didn't do anything wrong and in fact he
was just thought it was kind of kinky
[Laughter]
started early on the three-hour flight
three-hour play
mcgarrity
uh
commenced his indelicate behavior you
know there's a delicate in the story
it says there's a point where he was
doing it for one full hour one hour
do you realize if your mask comes down
below your nose for one second they're
all over you on a plane how did they not
notice this and stop this guy
i'm impressed with four times
um it's just
but is this is this like are you like
the the you like the story because it's
like a source of inspiration or what's
this you want to try this you know go
for it but
i think it's a
three-hour flight we're seeing is
wrestling all these
things happen on airplanes these days
well first thing i'd like to see happen
with airlines is to start flying and
landing and taking off on time a lot of
playing flights yeah there's been a lot
of delays lately all the people that are
trying to fly and they get late
zetter has such lots of delays if you
pull your mask down for 30 seconds the
entire plane swarms you and this guy's
beating it for an hour right yeah that's
the craziest thing like you put you take
a sip of your ginger ale you put it back
down and the stew is like put your mask
back over your nose okay i got to read
this last part this is insane i mean
this guy should be arrested
so amerigarity your irish buddy yeah
good guy massive a good guy good guy
masturbated with his exposed penis in
view of the female passenger on four
separate occasions
uh ambidextrously using both his left
and right hands you know explaining
talent
she suspected that mcgarrity ejaculated
because he licked a white substance from
his fingers what is happening here right
now holy crap what is this tyler why did
you want to address this story this is
how did you watch tyler this is all why
did you want to bring this story up
i don't know i think chris would have
won
whatever
golly can we take phone calls
yeah get us off the story
if anybody calls in in regards to the
story drop them immediately
somebody that's right
yeah jesus so if you got some callers
that have any questions or thoughts for
kevin go ahead and let's take some calls
yes we have paul
paul how you doing paul paul
good morning good morning how you doing
how you guys doing yeah so patrick first
things first i just want to say thank
you because you gave me high praise last
week and highlighting my comment you
said i made a freaking great point and i
had to i had to show my wife
and i made good points patrick said i
made a freaking great point today
but my uh my question is for for um
kevin yeah i met your brother back in 95
96 in a in a restaurant in the city with
my parents and when he walked in the
whole place got up and clapped oh wow
and he sat he sat down i was a kid and i
at that time i met lawrence taylor dave
maggie and a bunch of celebrities
but i was nervous going to talk to your
brother and i didn't want to do it at
the last minute my dad gave me the elbow
he says go go say hello i went up to him
a 16 17 year old kid
and he he was the one celebrity that
looked me in the eyes and actually
engaged with me
and uh was an awesome guy but i have a
question about him
so michelle sonnen talks about
conor mcgregor yeah and says the reason
why he has problems outside of the ring
is because he's too tied to his persona
in the ufc
and i'm just curious if that's what
chris had an issue with was he too tied
to the persona of comedy and that he
didn't know when to let it go did he
have any hobbies or interests outside of
it or was he always just addicted to you
know the laugh and making people or
making people laugh
right there's there that's probably
something that's true with uh with with
what happened i think
you know uh celebrity
is definitely not a uh
it's not a uh
natural uh way to live
i don't think there's a celebrity on uh
that ever is unaffected
by
the being famous
the nature of being famous is
contradictory to the way i think human
beings should live
and it does have a psychological effect
on you
i don't i don't think that's i think
that's pretty obvious
so yeah unless you have a good grip on
yourself celebrity can really um mess
with you you know being famous can
really mess with you
and i think that
it happened fast for him and and he he
was caught off guard by the whole yeah
it feels like he felt his role was to
always be the life of the party and make
sure everybody was entertained no matter
what it took and that's a lot of
pressure if you're putting that on
yourself i mean you feel that 24 7.
tough way to go through life it was too
much it was a weird world and i think
like celebrities and you know hollywood
is a strange thing to do to people it's
just you know the whole concept of
taking a person and making them famous
and that kind of thing it's strange and
it's uh it's not healthy it's definitely
not and if you don't have a good grip on
yourself it's it's thank you paul yeah
quick question for you regarding
celebrity them um
arguably chris would have been just as
big as adam sandler today i mean talk
about
like i think he's the number one guy
ever to come out of snl in terms of net
worth worth hundreds of millions of
dollars where do you think chris would
be today if he was still alive like well
he would have been shrek i mean he had
done shrek did you guys know that pat
did you know that he was the voice of
shrek he had recorded the whole uh first
movie yeah and then when he passed away
they thought okay we're gonna do
shrek234 right so then they had to bring
in mike myers but he was shrek it would
have been a totally different character
would have been a holy difference so
with shrek what else do you think he
would have been uh you know i don't know
he was in the in the mix to do
a really kind of a serious thing about
fatty arbuckle when he died and so that
would have been a good project for him
and there would have been there's a few
other different things that would have
been really good for him and i think he
would have probably done some serious
stuff because he was a good actor
so even some of the scenes in tommy boy
when he's crying on the little boat yeah
he's a girl good actor yeah for sure
yeah so he would have done some serious
stuff i'm sure you know how like jim
carrey went from
even adam sandler has gone from like
they have yeah billy madison and the
mask and then they've taken on more
serious roles
you think he would have gone from the
funny burly guy to a little more yeah
stable he would have done a great job i
believe it he would have done it great
we'll take another caller yeah we have a
dante
dante how you doing
hey how's it going guys kevin big fan of
your work on f is for family
thanks but had a question for adam uh
a little bit earlier ago you guys were
talking about the will smith chris rock
thing adam are you really justifying
that somebody can slap another person
and commit assault over hurt feelings
and words are you really okay with that
i'm not okay with someone who is that by
the way
i'm not i'm not okay with someone
slapping someone but he didn't shoot
someone he didn't beat the [ __ ] out of
somebody i my whole point is
does he deserve to be canceled because
he's a grown man slapped another man i
don't think he should be canceled should
he be
reprimanded and is the fallout justified
sure
but he didn't beat the [ __ ] out of
somebody he slapped a grown man like
adam you've been quoting this movie uh
all morning no that's assault brother
that's assault brother that's true dante
do you have a follow-up to that
well yeah i mean if i disagree with
something that adam says on the podcast
and i walked into the studio and slapped
him in the face would he be okay with
taking a slap his voice sounds very
familiar i think adam's feelings will
get hurt and he'd be upset by that
that's assault brother is it or no is
this a joke or is it is dante is real
dante is are you
are you one of adam's friends or you've
never met adam before
i've never met adam okay where are you
from downtown that he's defending
assault over he makes a good point
arrested what do we say like what should
have happened to will smith so i guess i
guess the question would be dante let me
see if you're saying this are you saying
like
so maybe you give us your your idea what
should be the repercussions for somebody
like will to walk up to chris rock on
national television at this point a few
billion people have seen it worldwide
what should be the repercussions for
that
assault charges that's what should
happen he should have been
taken away in handcuffs for putting his
hands on another person over hurt
feelings and words well what's worse
a grown man slapping another grown man
what happened with uh will smith and
chris rock or the other example i gave
you of jim carrey full-on making out
with an uninvited
uh woman who what's worse
what does it matter which is worth worse
both are wrong and shouldn't have
happened no but the point is he didn't
get he
then she should have been able to you
know when i see dante i'm just going to
slap him straight in the face straight
up
show me doctor watch dante fly out wait
outside of the valuetainment building
and record it put it on his social media
goes viral you're getting slapped in the
face by dante
you seem like you seem like you're a
little bit agitated and frustrated you
know um uh maybe there's a couple
stories we talked about today that could
be a source of inspiration for you but
have a wonderful day yeah yeah have a
good one dante do we have another one we
got eight more minutes do we have
another caller
johnny
yes aaron's on the line okay let's hear
aaron
hello guys how's it going how you doing
i just wanted to
talk briefly about like uh frederick
nietzsche right because he talked about
this 200 years ago
how
did we lose
yeah i think he's listening on the
playback we should just probably get rid
of him okay let's go to another one you
guys hear me yes we got you
that's all we have i like i like where
he was going though because nietzsche
says god is dead we have killed him and
there will be never there will never be
enough water to wash away the blood
yeah is that the angle he was going with
uh yeah that's he wanted to quote
nietzsche and and that kind of what
uh kevin touched on earlier with the
lack of religion
in the country and and one could say at
a broader aspect throughout the world um
the death of christianity and
and the the impact it's having on our
culture
yeah
tyler do you want to why don't you give
us a prayer real quick guys let's all
really join hands and give us a quick
prayer i'd like you to see how but you
know the you know what religion is the
number one and when they ask people to
check off what religion they identify as
you know the number one religion in
america is
um
agnostic do you have aaron back on so
aaron if you're back on you you ask us
the question we can hear you go ahead
hello
aaron go ahead
hey can you guys hear me yes
okay i don't know what was happening
but
okay
can you guys
we got you go ahead go ahead and ask the
question we can ask a question aaron are
you capable of that you guys familiar
with like frederick nietzsche yes he
talked about the loss of meaning and the
death of god like 200 years ago yep yes
you know and how you have to be in a
constant state of becoming otherwise you
end up in a state of nihilism
which i think is like really evident in
today's society more than anything else
like i'm 31 years old and i've had
set like more of my friends i've been to
their funerals than i have their
weddings you know and that is like a
huge
crisis in the world today so like i do
appreciate what you guys are doing and
what you guys are talking about you know
yeah isn't that yes and suicides have
gone up are these funerals because of
overdoses why i mean that's a let's not
just gloss over that you're saying
you're 31 you've been to more funerals
for your friends than weddings what's
the cause of these funerals bro
is he still there
he's gone so john do me a favor john
when we take callers ask what their
question is not what their comment is if
they can make a comment but we've got a
question
for kevin uh uh uh is what i would say
by the way let's wrap up with this so
your favorite comedians if you were to
say your favorite comedians who would
you say are your favorite comedians i
grew up with mel brooks
i grew up with you know the watching
those things uh i grew up with uh
um
uh
that that kind of comedy and also at the
beginning of snl like belushi and bill
murray and those guys dan aykroyd and
those guys i mean stand-up wise
i loved uh norm mcdonald he was a friend
of mine i went on the road with norm and
uh i loved him and uh a sandler and uh
i love uh
sebastian right now he's kind of
skulking
hysterical big time he is hysterical i
love him so we i laugh at him a lot
so those are the guys that have
influenced me if i could uh get to that
level it'd be great fantastic can i say
hi to kevin from one of his friends yeah
give myself a little plug in
i feel like i'm on the tonight show set
plug what i'm jealous on top of vt post
i have a new podcast starting one degree
of scandalous i've been working on this
thing for about two or three years and
my partner is another wisconsin famous
funny man
kate o'kalen oh yeah so cato told me to
say hi to you so we're gonna start this
podcast on podcast one where we're gonna
go back to every single
scandal that there's been and we're just
gonna have fun with it we're gonna talk
to the people that we're in the middle
of it we're not looking to you know blow
anything open or anything but just have
a good conversation and un unveil some
facts and take people people find it
it's gonna be on podcast one it's
starting in may yet or not no it's not
so just follow me on instagram at tom
center all the updates will be when it's
coming up when it is coming up let us
know we'll have you on and then we'll
put a link and we'll drive too that'll
be awesome
[Music]
where can people find you what are you
working on nowadays well uh i do a lot
of stand up so this weekend i'm in boca
raton um and i'm at the black box over
there and uh i have a website kevin
farley official and i also do a podcast
uh called offsides which is about
football and sports and that kind of
thing with uh
the savant kid who's like 12 years old
leo berman and another ex-football
player ed gantz and we talk a lot about
what's going on in in pro football most
literally 12 year old kid yeah he's you
know he's 16 sorry 16 but he's got he's
got a statistical mind he knows exactly
every step and of all things you could
be talking about you want to talk sports
is that what you're saying i love sports
yeah i love uh football college and uh
pro football yeah so we talk a lot about
that yeah and so uh that's our that's
our other podcast and i have another one
podcast called kevin farley on the road
which should talk about my daily life on
the road that kind of thing is the
majority of your time doing stand-up now
yeah a lot of it yep i have two movies
coming out one up and uh also the baby
pack those are those are coming out
later on in the in the year
so i have two movies coming out and then
i do voiceovers on f is for family but
they've wrapped it up so
i know wrapping up but the uh one last
question for you you made an appearance
on curb
you've made an appearance on a lot of uh
different things but one of one of the
funnier things i've seen is my favorite
show currently is always sunny in
philadelphia oh you did that too yeah
you did i was always sunny dealing with
all those guys those guys are genius you
know i mean and then the set is really
fun to go uh to be a part of because
danny devito's insistence
he's insane charlie yes all of them are
hilarious and they let you do you know
they're very cool on set so i played
this guy that was really a down-and-down
they're
in a ski bum and they're trying to have
fun and i'm like this real downer and
like fighting for custody of my
childhood so sad
i'm very turkey how much time did you
spend on set with those guys
10 59 folks we have the link below to go
find kevin farley's podcast twitter uh
he put it on there uh one of the best
comments of the day so far is zach
harris dante 2024. so dante out there
when you're running for office they they
they you someone's got your back here
for running from right now
tomorrow who do we have on tomorrow uh
big boy francis oh wow francis francis
who is going to be here tomorrow ufc
heavyweight
heavyweight champion
he's going to slap at him oh that would
be so that's assault
brother so anyways we'll see you guys
tomorrow with francis kevin appreciate
you coming out this was fantastic take
care bye-bye
you